l'avait promis elle est là c'était
compliqué non ça et dans sa loge à
l'américaine pas beaucoup de français à
la pas peur parce que là elle a couru à
mes oies che maintenant elle va à tour
il apprécie plus que pamela anderson est
avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces
matières si si
oui ces
femmes et la partie commence à faire
défaut ni très bien et vous oui
alors elle parle du peuple français
parce que ça deviendra un site
à côté de malibu
excès de graisse attendait pas comment
ça va pas mais là à eau parfaitement
bien mais on vous avait bien appris le
français en tout cas quand je vous vois
alors je ne dis pas votre âge pamela
vous êtes fan absolu de pamela car oui
pardon pour les fans ce n'est pas la
vraie pamela
mais vous appelez lisabeth elisabeth et
vous avez regardé à l' alerte à malibu
plus jeunes même s'ils veulent être
encore vous avez eu un coup de coeur
pour pamela anderson vous avez fait du
bodybuilding et puis après un petit peu
de chirurgie esthétique c'est ça voilà
tout à fait pour lui ressembler à vrai
dire oui au début quand j'étais plus
jeune j'étais très important jamais
assez costaud et plein de boutons au
visage et je me sentais pas au top
j'avais envie quand même chez moi il ya
eu un déclic quand j'ai eu et j'ai vu
les premières séries d' alerte à malibu
je dis
moi justement parce qu'elle le renfort
d'un n'a pas dit un mot de toutes les
missions
d'étaler le jihad et moi je suis pas
comme ça j je rêverais d'être comme ça
j'aimerais alors voulez vous devenu
parce que vous êtes fait refaire deux
fois la poitrine donc de bonnet b abonné
e et
il faut savoir que isabelle a fait
l'averse de bonnet e abonnés b
c'est facile ça flatteur
c'est rentrer
bébé ou non alors vous avez fait part
dont vous avez été également à
rétrécissement vaginale c'est pas très
bon oui pourquoi pourquoi pour le magma
vrai dire oui enfin si j'avais fait trop
de piercings j'avais quelques piercing g
comment vous saviez que comment vous
saviez pardon que pamela bien plus petit
que le vôtre c'est une vidéo qu'elle
avait qu'elle avait sorti avec obama
avec tommy lee lewis et va me donner
d'accord et vous que vous regardez la
sextape de pamela détient amer d un
centimètre de tron va dire d'eux quand
même deux
essais
et récits ce manga ginals quand vous
abaissez l'extérieur m'énerve c'est pas
l'intérieur non tu sais tout
dégueulasse alors pardon dont je
disposerai vous avez fait des injections
de botox
vous avez fait du laser pour refaire
l'ovale du visage le cou le front les
packs d'eau à dompter mais l'association
s'est passé pas des liftings c'est sans
doute nos malheureuses mais ça veut dire
coûter combien de devenir j'ai pas payer
la plupart du temps j'ai pas payé j'ai
fait des émissions de télé a été offert
du pt voilà donc en sait on
mais vous vivez de ça aujourd'hui au vu
de sa vive et de sa auparavant c'est dur
quand vous appelez vous inviter pour
être si vous pouviez due à des émissions
au début j'ai fait pas c'est mon choix
c'est ce qui a fait le déclic
oui il ya eu deux chats sauvages
quand quand j'étais invité non mais
après j'ai eu un agent argent qui m'a
qui m'a repéré qui m'a fait faire tout
là la france en discothèque en limousine
bien sûr lemozy les anniversaires
que 50 des années maintenant non pas que
vous avez même la même hygiène de vie
qu'elle mois j'emmerde ans c'est vrai
parce que je mangeais beaucoup beaucoup
de chocolat des glaces des conneries
donc j avais du mal à faire partir ma
petite bouée qui était hip hop hop hop
hop devenu sosie officiel en belgique
décidément les belges ont beaucoup qui
rendent sa série à il est remplacé parce
qu'elles devaient venir et donc nous ont
contactés c'est génial et j'y suis allé
à ça alors attendez mais pourquoi quand
même j'ai annoncé la vraie femme et là
ils n'ont pas pu la voir nous annoncer
tant qu'ils m'ont écoutez les mèdes
jeunes ont ils rien
[Applaudissements]
mais les journalistes y avait des
journalistes vous savez quand même rendu
compte parce qu'après le lendemain sur
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui quand
même attention fille sinon on va leur
dire qu'on leur envoie laurent nouna
cyril hanouna en boîte de nuit envoyons
laurent pas je dirais que c'était très
bien alors vous savez quoi je me suis
dit ça on vous avait filmé pour
tellement vrai excellente émission de
fer d'nrj12 de tel de l'époque
ces images c'est gratuit
elisabeth sosie officiel de pamela
anderson au delà des shows et de cette
ressemblance avec la mêlée anderson elle
avait un autre objectif devenir
chanteuse la belgique a également
raconté un album alors sa carrière de
chanteuse n'a malheureusement pas encore
décollé en revanche il y à du nouveau
côté silhouette elisabeth vient tout
juste de se faire opérer de la poitrine
moi c'est lolo lamborghini
grosses poitrines appelé style pin-up
j'ai la fascination des gros simple que
chez fo j'ai toujours été attirée je
trouve ça beau
est ce que pour me faire un petit
plaisir parce que pour les fans ma
mellal cours oui vous pouvez courir un
petit peu bah oui à la façon moi je
souhaite moi
[Applaudissements]
le dire
la caméra
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
non
areva
[Musique]
tu rêvais retrouve dans les séries
américaines ils s'arrêtaient il ya
marqué starting with le coup d'arrêt ce
métier de leurs maux ça viendra les
questions viennent de tous les pervers
ils sont là alors nous n'a dormi comme
une émission média précision ce qui a
fait le succès des retenues ou c'est
quand les filles courent au ralenti sur
la place est vrai est en fait c'était ou
question d'économie c'est quand ils ont
fait un premier épisode qui devait durer
cinq ans pile il n'avait pas le budget
de faire 50 minutes donc ils sont pris
toutes les séances où les filles courent
et ils ont mis au ralenti du coup ça
ravagé leur titre et c'est votre des
socio économique c'est devenu un succès
car c'est génial là bas n'est pas sûr
qu'on aura là mais une même foi de
laurent luna monde et on va essayer le
rang moi je suis je suis ravi c'est sûr
énormément de bien de voir une jolie
demoiselle way assis en maillot de bain
ce que les hommes sont des boudins quand
vous passez en vacances et je voulais
vous poser une petite question oui
dites-moi est-ce que vous avez des
petites relation amoureuse avec certains
animateurs télévision ou pas
ça fait quand même longtemps vous êtes
dans les gta les appâtant avec vous oui
on m'a déjà proposé si je voulais faire
bas une sorte de série a même des
sketches où tu vas caméra cachée ah oui
pas pareil et par contre je dirai pas le
nom non mais qui voulait me faire
tourner j'aurais dû j'aurais dû faire
mais j'ai pas accepter parce que je suis
avec mon homme depuis 22 ans il lui la
campagne partout donc le match lui qui
voulez-vous faire tourner ces deux
boulots vous allez voir il faut être
qu'elle tourne et c'est oui ou c'est non
mais d'aller au restaurant avec lui non
je fais très connu henri ciel du prénom
initial non initiation d'issia ne sera
pas initial jute initiale prévue lé rnr
initial n'a pas pu lancer un adroit
assez assez aymeric un nom assez de lait
non tous qui je ne peux pas dire c'est
conditionnel c'est une émission au la
vache ou
un indice sur votre écran donc ça
devrait passer
oui j'ai dernière question on vous a je
pense qu'à retrouver
je vivais à chaque fois que je vais
regarder sera pas totale et votre petite
touche personnelle et courir
complètement dessus est ce que depuis
que vous avez totalement arrêtée ou pas
pas ça dépend ça n'est pas encore ça me
rend parfois mon corps est totalement
nuit oui
[Musique]
mais non
non mais non mais non rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
merci femmes et hommes
[Applaudissements]
mais là
jamais vous êtes des malades pensé que
c'était une vanne je pense et
je pensais vraiment que c'était une
bonne vous avez vos propres micro non
mais c'est une blague mais sortez la
non non
[Rires]
je fais très longue
vous avez ça
[Applaudissements]
j'ai
battu mu avait pas manqué de dresser un
monsieur qui est
chauffé mais je pensais que c'était une
blague ne s'est écoulée autour du don je
vous jure je vous jure que je ne savais
pas jamais vraiment croire
celle ci a mis un beau chêne micro
acheter un micro qui est pas le mien
donneriez connaît aujourd hui elle court
et je pensais que bon
c'est que c'est pas pareil
tu peux l'enlever posage de leur public